[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 lipdo 26 minutes pour
revenir sur l'actualité de la semaine
dans les yvelines
au sommaire de ce vendredi 6 mars le
domaine de mais rod est dédié au service
des personnes en perte d'autonomie
organisé une journée portes ouvertes
l'occasion de découvrir un nouvel espace
dédié aux solutions nouvelles pour une
de nos reportages dans cette édition
le projet de loi de réforme du système
universel des retraites a été votée
cette semaine à l'assemblée nationale
après des débats tumultueux dans
l'hémicycle c'est au tour du sénat de
plancher sur les textes
sophie primas sénatrice l ère des
yvelines sera avec nous en plateau pour
en parler un premier cas de korda virus
confirmé dans les yvelines le
département présente son premier bilan
carbone et la culture facteur d'égalité
sociale dans le rapport de la députée
roland berger
nous reviendrons sur ce qui a marqué
votre semaine dans les yvelines
jeudi soir c'était le dernier conseil
communautaire pour saint quentin en
yvelines avant les élections municipales
de nombreux points étaient à l'ordre du
jour comme les finances taux de la taxe
d'enlèvement des ordures ménagères ou
taux de fiscalité directe locale ce
dernier taux n'augmentera pas en 2020
concernant les travaux la construction
d'un parc relais de 900 places à la gare
de la verrière a été approuvé un parking
qui sera gratuit avec le pass navigo
annuel coût des travaux 13,7 millions
d'euros des travaux qui devraient
débuter en juin en 2020 elles sont plus
de cent sept mille dans les yvelines et
représente plus de 7% de la population
les personnes âgées de 75 ans ou plus un
nombre qui devrait encore s'accroître
avec le vieillissement de la population
et qui pose la question du maintien à
domicile au domaine du mes rentes et à
magny les hameaux les professionnels du
secteur étaient réunis pour présenter
leurs technologies et astuces un
reportage de nicolas kirillovitch c'est
une réalité qui touche de plus en plus
de français avec l'âge et les
difficultés corporelle qui s'accumulent
il devient très difficile de réaliser
les gestes les plus simples
voilà une facilité d'ouverture de porte
simplement avec l'aide d'une carte
voilà ce qui est très pratique pour des
personnes à mobilité réduite
ouvrir une porte c'est voler ou encore
déplacer des objets le quotidien peu
tourné à l'enfer lorsque la perte
d'autonomie s'accélère heureusement
aujourd'hui une série de technologies et
d'outils existent pour soulager les
concernés
l'idée c'est de montrer qu'on peut aussi
rester à domicile malgré parfois de très
gros handicap ou de des maladies comme
alzheimer avec pas forcément du père
friess personnel 24 heures sur 24
mais grâce à des outils qui du coup vont
vous permettre ce maintien à domicile
réunis au domaine du mes rentes et pour
ses portes ouvertes les professionnels
de santé de l'habitat de saint quentin
en yvelines ont pu ainsi présenter leurs
solutions pour continuer à vivre chez
soi
les personnes qui occupent qui arrive
n'a pas de service dès demain ça c'est
des systèmes anti dérapante s'est vite
principalement visés par l'opération les
personnes âgées bien sûr mais les aidant
aussi la personne a des grosses
difficultés à se relever ou même
s'asseoir
ça peut être intéressant si on peut voir
des références donc là elle monsieur m'a
donné sa carte parce que effectivement
si je vais à la formation m'a jamais
proposé sa fin d'un cycle
dans les yvelines plus de 7% de la
population a 75 ans au plus
un chiffre inférieur à la moyenne
nationale de 9 %
l insee prévoit un doublement de ces
données pour 2050
en conséquence est considéré comme
adopté le projet de loi instituant un
système universel de retraite
[Applaudissements]
c'était dans la nuit de mardi à mercredi
les députés voter contre les motions de
censure repose au premier ministre et
son 49,3 pour faire passer le projet de
loi ordinaire sur les retraites
un débat dans une assemblée nationale
tendues depuis le début de l'examen de
la réforme des retraites et ses plus de
40 mille amendements
le projet de loi ordinaire et donc
adopté en première lecture et va
poursuivre son chemin au sénat le projet
de loi organique quant à lui a été
adopté jeudi par 98 voix contre une les
oppositions de gauche et l air ayant
quitté l'hémicycle
on rappelle l'objectif du gouvernement
qui est de faire passer la loi avant
l'été sophie primas vous êtes avec nous
bonjour bonjour alors vous êtes
sénatrice les républicains des yvelines
est notamment président de la commission
des affaires économiques
ce projet de loi ordinaire il arrivera
fin avril au sénat son président gérard
larcher a annoncé vouloir un débat de
fond sans obstruction comment se prépare
un événement d'une loi dans un tel
contexte
alors vous avez raison normalement il
est inscrit enfin il pas encore inscrit
puisque la conférence des présidents n'a
pas statué et normalement le timing
c'était fin avril le président larcher
après avoir demandé que ce texte dans un
premier temps ne soit plus en lecture
accélérée c'est à dire qu'il fasse deux
navettes entre l'assemblée nationale et
le sénat
il avait reçu une fin de non recevoir
par le premier ministre a demandé cette
fois quinze jours supplémentaires donc
fin avril ou mi mai en fonction de la
réponse du premier ministre dans les
jours qui viennent dans les heures qui
viennent
nous abordons la lecture de ce texte
avec responsabilité puisque en fait on a
bien vu que en raison à la fois de
l'attitude du gouvernement et l'attitude
des oppositions de l'extrême gauche en
particulier à l'assemblée nationale on a
assisté à tout aux jeux du cirque mais
sûrement bas à un débat apaisé et
responsable sur un probablement une des
réformes les plus importantes de ce
quinquennat puisque c'est ça engage
pratiquement 15 % 14 % du budget de
l'état chaque année c'est un changement
profond d'eux
la méthode et de la politique de
retraite c'est un changement profond de
ceux de l'idée qu'on se fait de la
société derrière c'est beaucoup plus
profond c'est pas des mesures justes
technique c'est un changement profond de
modèle de société et nous voulons au
sénat aborder cette discussion avec
responsabilité le maximum de sérénité
par le contexte on dit qu'ils allaient
au parlement est également dans la
société avec les nombreuses
manifestations ça rajoute encore plus
l'importance de la loi et sa symbolique
et au pas mais voyez c'est une encore
une fois c'est une c'est une réforme qui
est très importante parce qu'elle
bouscule fondamentalement le modèle de
société
donc on est dans une méthode qui est
effroyable c'est à dire qu'on réfléchit
pendant deux ans on nomme à aux
commissaires qui vous donne un rapport
sur ce rapport indépendamment des
péripéties liées à monsieur delevoye et
ses activités ce rapport finalement il
est jeté à la poubelle
aussitôt arrivés on relance des
concertations en huit clos on a on ne
met pas le parlement à l'intérieur des
discussions on écoute pas on n'écoute
personne et on arrive à l'assemblée
nationale avec un texte n'est pas
terminée et preuve qu'il n'était pas
terminé c'est que le gouvernement
lui-même au fil de la discussion apporte
des amendements dans la nuit qui précède
des discussions et c'est donc ce n'est
pas ficelé le financement qui est quand
même un sujet majeur n'est pas réglé et
tout ça ça apporte de la confusion tout
ça ça apporte de la peur et chacun
d'entre nous en fait et anxieux donc sur
vos de savoir pour son propre cas ce qui
va se passer pour le gars de ses enfants
ce qui va se passer
et encore une fois ça bouscule tellement
notre modèle de société que je pense que
c'est une discussion qui a été mal
engagée
or justement le financement c'est un
point important mercredi au palais du
luxembourg vous receviez trois
économistes qui analyse et un peu ce
système et le financement c'est quelque
chose qui pointait qui souhaite qu'il y
en ait un peu inquiet est ce que c'est
quelque chose sur lequel vous allez
particulièrement discuté aussi on va
particulièrement décédé
discuter si on en a les moyens et vous
savez que le conseil d'état a été très
sévère avec avec le texte le projet de
loi du gouvernement disons que ils
n'étaient pas financés et qu'on n'avait
pas du tout d'information dans l'étude
d'impact sur son financement
encore une fois c'est pratiquement 1 6%
du budget chaque année donc c'est
quelque chose de majeur dans dans le
financement
vous avez une étude très intéressante
qui paru hier qui indique que le trou ne
sera comblé de la sécurité sociale ne se
répètent 17 milliards mais de 30
milliards à l'horizon 2030
on voit bien donc on a besoin de
sérénité on a besoin vraiment que cette
retraite au delà de son modèle soient
financées c'est quand même le sujet
numéro un alors je sais que le président
de la république dans son allocution sur
les retraites a dit qu'il n'est pas
question d'argent entre nous et que tout
ça c'était pas prioritaire qu'est ce qui
était prioritaire c'était la réforme de
fond de la retraite et de son modèle
moi je crois que c'est tout à fait
l'inversé le le sujet numéro un pour les
français c'est de savoir s'ils vont
pouvoir toucher une retraite dans les
années qui viennent c'est leur pension
vont être baissés ou si elles vont être
stables si elles sont stables sur quels
indices elles vont être indexés et c est
de savoir comment tout ça est financé
par le budget de la sécurité sociale et
par le budget de l'état
parmi eux pour revenir aux quinze jours
qui ont été demandé de délai à part le
président du sénat c'est aussi par
rapport à la conférence financement
justement qui réunit les partenaires
sociaux donc ce soit les syndicats du
patronat et des salariés et donc leurs
rapports concernant l'équipe finance
système de retraite doit être remis fin
avril c'est quelque chose sur lequel
vous comptez vous appuyer j'assure c'est
quelque chose qu'on demande encore une
fois on ne peut pas mener cette réforme
sans avoir avait avec avec des avec les
yeux fermés on ne peut pas c'est
impossible et donc je pense que la
demande du président du sénat à défaut
d'avoir de ne pas avoir obtenu la fin de
la procédure accélérée
c'est le minimum c'est le minimum pour
que le parlement
puisse discuter sereinement avec
responsabilité d'une loi encore je le
dis encore qui engage une partie
conséquences de notre budget et qui
engage un modèle de société en fait la
difficulté de cette réforme c'est
qu'elle fait les deux en même temps
c'est à dire qu'elle elle vise il faudra
et qu'elle vise arriver à l'équilibré
des retraites qui est la seule chose qui
permet de la pérennité des retraites et
la stabilité et la sécurité des
retraites est en même temps le
gouvernement veut un changement de
modèle je crois que ces deux éléments là
ensemble c'est trop
alors la procédure est encore plus
accéléré avec ce fameux 49,3 oui parce
que le sénat peut amener à se montrer
comme un véritable contre-pouvoir
finalement sur cette réforme
oui ces mets d'ailleurs c'est le rôle du
sénat d'être contre-pouvoir le président
larcher dit souvent on n'est pas anti
pouvoir les contre pouvoirs et on voit
bien là le rôle du sénat qui va être qui
ne peut pas être soumis 49,3 il peut
être soumis est ce qu'on appelle un vote
bloqué c'est à dire qu'au bout d'un
moment si le gouvernement trouve que les
choses sont trop lentes ou ne vont pas
dans leur sens ils peuvent faire un vote
bloqué mais là je crois que ce serait
une provocation tel n'en mesurait pas
les conséquences
donc on va avoir le temps au sénat et on
prendra le temps de discuter point à
point et aussi proposer des alternatives
bien sûr c'est notre rôle de sénateur à
chaque fois de d'essayer de apporter un
peu de raison d'apporter un petit peu
d'apaisement dans le l'examen des lois
justement qu'est-ce que vous allez
proposer au sein du groupe droite et
sans qui est majoritaire au sénat
alors je n'ai pas encore la feuille de
route exacte de ce que la commission des
affaires sociales va va exactement
proposé parce que le modèle que nous
nous défendons de réforme des retraites
est un modèle totalement différent donc
je ne sais pas encore si la commission
des affaires sociales au sénat va
proposer un changement total de
paradigme ou si nous allons essayer
d'améliorer le texte du gouvernement
en acceptant le principe de sa
modification mais nous notre notre notre
credo depuis le début c'est à dire la
vérité aux français c'est de dire qu'il
existe que trois paramètres pour
équilibrer les retraites qui sont l'âge
de départ le niveau des retraites et le
niveau de cotisation si on prend les
niveaux des retraites est bien pour
équilibrer le système il faudrait
baisser les retraites de deux ennemis
pour cent donc ça je pense que
socialement c'est juste impossible et
politiquement juste impossible si on
prend le niveau des cotisations
patronales il faudrait augmenter les
potes et poti nation patronales d'un
ennemi pour cent et ça dans le contexte
économique dans la recherche de
compétitivité pour les entreprises
ce n'est pas possible d'autant que nos
prélèvements sociaux sont parmi les plus
élevés d'europe
il ne reste donc que l'âge et je crois
que depuis le début
parler d'âge pivot d'âge ceci d'âge cela
il faut simplement dire aux gens qu'il
va falloir travailler un petit peu plus
longtemps alors on arrive à la fin de
cette rente rien mais avant de se
quitter actualité oblige voulait faire
un petit mot sur le corner virus il
continue de se répandre en français même
dans les yvelines avec des cas déclarés
jeudi
nous reviendrons sur cette information
dans cette édition avec vous je voulais
aborder la question économique car on
voit que cette crise sanitaire a des
conséquences économiques internationales
en coop et on s'attendre en france mais
écoutez je pense que les effets
économiques sont elles vont être à la
fois immédiats rêvons de longue durée
on a des effets immédiats qui sont
d'abord la diminution du nombre
d'étrangers qui viennent en france donc
ça ça d impact immédiat sur le sur le
tourisme le la commission européenne a
indiqué depuis début janvier on avait
déjà perdu 2 milliards sur l'ensemble de
l'europe
mais ça a des impacts aussi sur
l'activité française et je parle je
pense en particulier à tout ce qui est
hôtels restaurants tout la société de
loisirs de culture l'événementiel et
traiteur qui aujourd'hui ont des reculs
de chiffre d'affaires allant jusqu'à 70
80 % donc on est là dans un effet
interne à la france qui est très violent
extrêmement violent et le gouvernement
a pris des mesures moi je lui rends
hommage j'allais dire d'avoir sorti ce
que j'appelle le kit gilet jaune
mais ce sont des entreprises qui sont
extrêmement fragilisée et dont on peut
douter de la pérennité aujourd'hui dans
le temps parce qu'elles ont la crise du
gilet jaune
elles ont les violences dans les
centres-villes conduire est très très
longtemps
elles ont eu la réforme les émeutes
j'allais dire lié à la réforme des
retraites au moins deux ans au mois de
décembre
hélas les effets du coronavirus moi je
suis pour ma part assez inquiète
merci sophy de jimenez venu sur ce
plateau je rappelle cette sénatrice les
républicains d'eysines et présidente de
la commission des affaires économiques
on passe au reste de l'actualité de la
semaine
le corona virus qui touche les yvelines
donc un premier cas décelés mercredi
nous a été confirmé jeudi par les
services de l'état la personne concernée
est un homme habitant de versailles dont
l'âge serait relativement avancé d'après
les informations communiquées par la
préfecture il a été transféré dans un
hôpital parisien
l' agence régionale de santé enquête
pour comprendre les origines de la
contamination
le patient ne revient pas d'une zone à
risque comme la chine ou le nord de
l'italie
son entourage a reçu des masques de
protection et sort en confinement
pendant une période de 14 jours
pas de mesures spécifiques mises en
place sur le territoire la préfecture
tient à rassurer
il s'agit d'un cas isolé les évident ne
sont pas un foyer épidémique dès la
semaine dernière déjà le président du
conseil départemental n'était pas
alarmiste au micro de michael et demi
d'eau je pense qu'il faut rassurer nos
concitoyens
c'est une épidémie mais c'est pas la
grippe espagnole
de l'avant guerre il ya un danger mais
le danger surtout pour des personnes
déjà malades et affaiblis donc pas de
panique
mais après les structures de santé
publique en france ce sont anciennes et
solide
on peut leur faire confiance du moins je
le pense françois de mazières maire de
versailles c30 retenu jeudi avec le
directeur de l'hôpital mignot à propos
de ce premier cas un dispositif est mis
en place à compter de ce jour au centre
hospitalier de versailles pour la prise
en charge d'éventuels nouvelles
contaminations versailles d'après les
informations de nos confrères de 7,8
actuant deuxième cas est suspect celui
d'une mère de famille signalé jeudi
pour tout renseignement sur le coc u19
n'oubliez pas le numéro spécial
déclenchée par le gouvernement le 0 800
130 000 en cas de symptômes c'est le
sein nu qu'il faut contacter au 15 pour
notre rubrique ça s'est passé nous vous
proposons un retour sur une président
précédente vague d'épidémie
dès 2004 la france a été à et avait
élaboré un plan de prévention dans le
cadre du virus h5n1
malgré tout elle a dû subir les
conséquences notamment économique de
l'infection
[Musique]
un peu plus de six mois maintenant que
les temps sont difficiles pour cette
société d'abattage de volailles
habituellement l'abattoir vend entre
1200 et 1500 volailles par semaine
aujourd'hui les ventes ont chuté à 400
pour les mauvaises semaines 800 quand
l'actualité n'évoque plus la grippe
aviaire en france pour le moment il n'y
a pas de risques parce que tout est
contrôlé il ya les services sanitaires
et vétérinaires les éleveurs sont
contrôlés fréquemment donc je pense pas
qu'il risque de psychose quoi mais
il ya une peur c'est clair il ya une
peur donc ça joue dessus que son moral
les consommateurs depuis quelques mois
deviennent plus prudents des affichettes
ont été posées à côté de la caisse afin
de les rassurer mais beaucoup tout de
même préfèrent directement interpellé
les employés temps en temps dans un
temps way moody's qui a pas de sujet pas
de problème
j'en ai six heures et discussions la
porte est ouverte
80% des transactions de cette entreprise
concerne directement le poulet un
véritable manque à gagner depuis que la
grippe aviaire fait des victimes dans le
monde depuis les vacances d'été cet
établissement à travailler seulement six
semaines pleines notamment pendant le
ramadan et les festivités de noël
le gérant s'est donc séparé de certains
collaborateurs et à peu près 50 à 60 %
de pertes depuis le mois de
septembre donc on a dû séparer de deux
employés et ce ne sont pas que les
sociétés d'abattage qui souffre déjà
certains des négocions avec lesquels il
avait l'habitude de travailler ont mis
la clé sous la porte
son entreprise est d'ailleurs en vente
même si la grippe aviaire n'est pas
forcément la raison il c'est toute la
filière qui va fermer c'est d'aliments
jusqu'au jusqu'au consommateur quoi donc
c'est toute la filière c'est à dire les
éleveurs toute la filière
[Musique]
la mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites s'est poursuivie mardi
ce mardi matin donc des salariés de tels
srm arnaud et airbus se sont rassemblés
dans la zone d'activités de la clé
saint-pierre elancourt plusieurs
revendications le retrait de la réforme
l'augmentation des salaires et contester
la suppression des postes annoncées chez
airbus nous explique les explications au
micro de patrick jane est exclu thales
s'est aujourd'hui c'est une pompe à
bille est énorme
on a eu des chiffres d'ailleurs jeu il
ya quelques jours la au niveau du groupe
tout le monde est content sauf nous
voilà dans la convention nationale
collective de la métallurgie est en
cours de renégociation et là on
on constate des baisses du socle social
énorme aujourd'hui
le patronat a essayé de mettre dans la
convention sera payé au poste
aujourd'hui vous êtes ingénieur vous
gagnerez
x euros par mois eh bien demain vous
serez peut-être plus ingénieurs vont
vous donnera notre poste de mon petit
ingénieur on va appeler ça comme ça et
vous gagnerez - le premier tour des
élections municipales aura lieu le
dimanche 15 mars prochain les candidats
avaient jusqu'au 27 février pour
déclarer leur liste complète à la
préfecture et dans les yvelines elles
sont 490 les étiquettes sont fidèles à
l'histoire politique du département
plutôt ancré à droite
quatre-vingt onze listes divers droite
et quarante-et-une diverses entre on
note tout de même 45 liste divers gauche
et 30 liste divers sans étiquette
enfin c'est une certitude il n'y aura
qu'un seul tour dans 74 communes du
département qui compte une ou deux
listes données complètes à retrouver sur
le site de la préfecture des yvelines
le département des yvelines qui a
présenté son premier bilan carbone il a
été dressé par la collectivité avec
l'accompagnement d'un cabinet de conseil
depuis le deuxième semestre 2010 9 les
huit principales sources d'émissions de
gaz à effet de serre ont été dévoilées
achat de fonctionnement amortissement de
la voiture est en tête ce sont les
collèges qui occupent les trois
premières places
déplacement des élèves responsables de
21% des émissions énergie des bâtiments
est encore repas scolaires pour 16 et 15
% le département à intégrer cet enjeu
environnemental au coeur de sa stratégie
pour améliorer ce bilan carbone propos
recueillis par michael et demi d'euros
on va tout faire pour qu'il y ait et la
quantité la qualité puisque vous évoquez
les collèges on veut sur choir au
programme de reconstruction ou de
construction de neuf collèges de façon à
en faire
des collèges écologique et en
particulier en structure bois
donc on prend du retard mais nous nous
efforcerons néanmoins de financer ces
neuf collèges c'est vrai que ça risque
de nous coûter un peu plus cher mais on
fera cet effort la culture pour tous et
la thématique du rapport parlementaire
remis par la députée lrn yvelinoise
aurore bergé le mois dernier 60
propositions parmi lesquelles
l'inscription des droits culturels dans
la constitution
l'introduction de la santé culturelle
dans le carnet de santé
et encore le déploiement de mal à lire
dans les lieux d'accueil de la petite
enfance
pour cela elle a contacté 450 acteurs
culturels dans 25 départements dont les
yvelines c'était vraiment une volonté
d'aller sur tous les territoires du plus
rurales au plus urbain évidemment aussi
dans les yvelines à saint quentin en
yvelines au théâtre national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines à benne ou là
où vous avez une configuration est
différente puisque c'est une structure
qui est soutenu par la municipalité
vous allez avoir à la fois du théâtre
mais aussi le cinéma
évidemment ici présents catherine pégard
qui préside le château de versailles
donc des acteurs très différents même
sur notre territoire
l'intégralité de cette interview est à
retrouver dans le circuit journal du
mardi 3 mars henri paye sur notre triste
internet notre site internet où notre
application mobile et justement nous
vous proposons de découvrir cet
établissement de belles la barbacane ce
centre culturel mène plusieurs actions
tout au long de l'année notamment des
représentations théâtrales ouverte aux
scolaires
or il y renonce
[Applaudissements]
la troupe de la pièce intra muros saluée
par les scolaires après une
représentation uniquement dédié à ce
public venu du centre yvelines ah ben
le théâtre la barbacane et géré par un
syndicat intercommunal sept communes
sont associées et travaillent ensemble
sur la programmation
la spécificité de ce bâtiment c'est
qu'il a été construit au vert ya une
trentaine d'années avec l'idée que tout
le monde allait pouvoir se croiser et
une bibliothèque municipale un volet
associatif qui est porté par la ville de
ben avec différentes activités de la
pratique artistique
et puis dans notre salle de spectacle en
effet il ya spectacle mais aussi cinéma
plusieurs fois dans l'année les
représentations théâtrales sont suivis
de bord plateau un moyen de partager qui
permettent aux scolaires de se
familiariser avec le monde du spectacle
j'aime bien la transmettre un petit
savoir l'autre chose partager un peu
avec avec les jeunes parce que moi dans
mon parcours personnel j'ai souvent
rencontré des professeurs en que ce soit
de sport de lettres de même de maths ou
de géographie qui m'ont souvent apporter
autre chose que leur matière en décembre
dernier l'établissement culturel a reçu
la visite d'horreur bergé la députée
yvelinois s'est inspiré de ce lieu pour
son rapport sur le développement de la
culture pour tous donc l'enjeu c'était
parler de comment à l'échelle d'un
territoire
on arrive à créer des mutualisations des
convergences des circulations qui
viennent parfois jusqu'à notre lieu
théâtre mais parfois c'est le théâtre
qui va sur sur les villes
du syndicat un accompagnement à la
culture qui a également permis à la
barbacane de devenir le premier lieu des
yvelines à porter le label scène
conventionnée pour la musique
première grande route grandes courses
européennes sur route de la saison le
départ du paris nice 2020 devrait avoir
lieu ce dimanche depuis la commune de
plaisir
lancement du château pour une boucle de
154 km le peloton partir le lendemain de
chevreuse direction le loiret une
onzième édition consécutive dans les
yvelines qui pourraient être perturbés
par le coronavirus plusieurs équipes se
sont retirés de la course pour cette
78ème édition et on en arrive à la fin
de ce numéro du 7-8 l'hebdo merci de
nous avoir suivi on se quitte avec des
images de la seine en crue tournée
vendredi matin du côté de poissy retour
de votre information locale dès lundi
avec le 7-8 journal en attendant bon
week-end sur tv 78
on
mais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]